it all starts with copper copper
conducts heat and electricity with
little resistance here it's drawn into a
thin wire for cable production making
copper cables is the busques family's
business their conductors move trains
cars and robots and carry energy or
death
the copper wire has to be twisted
insulated and stranded and it's up to
Sabina bucks goes as technical director
of production to decide precisely how
who dug in south asia of course there
are lots of tips and tricks to putting
together a stranded cable like this
especially with such non-standard
constructions but I think I better stop
talking right there there are company
secrets you know and company secrets are
meant to stay in the family the youngest
family member is 6-week old Matty petah
will he grow up here to death of info he
definitely will if for no other reason
that I'm totally involved here so he'll
spend lots of time here I think when I
come into the company on the weekend
I'll have him with me a lot of course I
hope he'll eventually develop some
interest and cables and conductors like
his mother Sabina puskás will be running
the company stress that Ozma I'm glad my
sister's taking it on so it'll remain in
the family's hands we've known she could
do it right from the start one thought
and we've also known that our sister
would be the one to take over the
business Peter busques founded the
company in 1947 and passed it on to his
son that was quite a while ago wasn't it
yo yes 26 years ago from Jonathan now
Peter Brooks cos is the senior partner
ah come on you be home he looks back on
many years in the company which he made
into a major player now SI b takes in
more than 90 million euros of annual
revenues worldwide Zebina busques
already has a controlling stake but the
family still make some decisions
together on things like new investment
for instance a new production hall will
be going up here this year we still have
a couple of empty spots on the world map
South America the Middle East Africa at
me like oh we don't have a strong
presence there and South Africa would be
a possible industrial location but we do
have a vision for our future
I bought vision still there are some
clouds on the horizon the economic
crisis in southern Europe has cut demand
for cables and Germany is not cheap for
any manufacturing involving work by hand
competitors have moved production to
low-wage countries visit me we're at
least twice as expensive as Asian
countries that's clear but you still
have customers how do they do it via my
own coconut if everything you see around
here is headed to Asia to a German
machine maker though we're not at all
out of reach for our customers and
provide we know where they have their
problems and we're problem solvers we're
not able suppliers as much as problem
solvers these days a month on with
Infibeam rhythm for example a customer
would like to send both data and energy
over one cable with no interference no
matter how heavy the load in the lab SI
b tests the cable to see how many
bending cycles it tolerates it has to be
millions yeah and it's left its bum yeah
and whenever a problem comes up Sabina
puskás is the one to solve it